good morning believe nation today's
message is compete with yourself over to
you Sophia Amoruso I think anyone if
they're smart and resourceful can like
use the Internet and here's the
resources that you know that they have
or that they create for themself to do
great things whatever the magnitude of
greatness is for you you know just
because I'm on a stage or because I have
a platform and wrote a book doesn't mean
that your level of greatness is like any
less than mine I think that's important
for people to understand because we live
in a culture where celebrities are
idolized and and I talking in girlboss
about being your own Idol and competing
with yourself I do my best work when I
compete with myself I think it's super
healthy to see yourself as your biggest
competitor I look at my youtube channel
and I want to do better than I did the
day before right I did better than I did
yesterday you know I have almost two
hundred thousand subscribers on the
channel whatever I did whatever I do
today I want to do more tomorrow I want
to do more the next day I wanna have
more comments when I have more likes
what I have more views and I'm
constantly comparing myself to how I was
last month
last week last year at this time and one
it shows a growth right it's good to see
that hey wow look how much I've grown in
the past year or past month and two I
think it also helps me stay motivated to
want to continue to do better on on the
flip side I think that there's a fine
edge that you need to walk when you're
comparing yourself to other people I
think you can do one of two things I
think it can really help you can
motivate you that sometimes what I do
with my youtube channel as well for a
while at my agency that I'm with I was
the number two guy and said I want to be
number one right I wanted to pass that
guy who is number one and it motivated
me to want to do better but I think
sometimes it can also maybe seem like
it's too big a goal too far away you
know if you're just starting up a
YouTube channel right now and you try to
compare yourself to where I'm at right
now that's not a fair comparison right
like if you're tracking your growth
versus mine I'm going to
scale you and that might discourage you
and so that may not be a great target to
follow and so I think that's sometimes a
bit of a disconnect where you want to
pick people to compete with who you can
reach right in the short term in the
medium term in the long term people who
who motivate you and don't bring you
down I think that's the biggest thing
where you know we do a workout class
here that I'm a part of and we're all at
different stages right I do it Nina does
it there's a couple other people right
men women different body types and
people can do things faster than others
some people do more reps or more weights
and others and comparing you know
comparing myself to somebody else isn't
great right what I want to do is I want
to do more reps than I did the day
before I want to do more weights than I
did the week before right what if I'm
tracking how much I weigh or how much
muscle I have there's no point comparing
myself to Nina I'm comparing myself to
where I was the week before the month
before or the day before potentially and
so I think one yes compare yourself to
yourself and always try to get better
and try to suck a little bit less every
day until you get good and try to get
better every single day and then when
you compare yourself to others try to
find somebody that you respect you look
up to but it's not so far out of reach
that when you compare yourself you just
see the numbers going out of control
that you see somebody that hey I can I
can catch this person and that gives you
the fire the motivation because the goal
seems too big it can be daunting and it
can actually discourage you or if it
seems a little more realistic still
stretch but realistic feel like I think
I can catch that person I can catch that
competitor then that can also serve as
inner fire to help you get going
so the question today today is I'm
curious what do you compare yourself on
today's version of you versus yesterday
this is last week use the last month or
last year what metrics are you looking
at to compare yourself to where you were
before and if you're comparing yourself
to somebody else what are you comparing
yourself on again what are the metrics
what are you trying to get better at I'm
really curious to find out leave it in
discussion below I'm gonna join in thank
you guys so much for watching
have an amazing day continue to believe
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot event special